now one country making slow progress is
the philippines and now its president
rodrigo duterte is threatening to jail
people
who refuse to be vaccinated let's go
live to our correspondent in manila
jamila olinden jamila so why are people
not getting vaccinated in the
philippines is it a question of vaccine
hesitancy or rather
the fact that there are no vaccines
well it's a complex problem foley as you
know the president uh
in his latest statement basically said
that those who refuse
vaccine will end up going to jail or can
be jailed by
state forces but that was quickly
contradicted by the department of
justice secretary himself who basically
said that the law
actually does not compel or cannot force
anybody
um if they refuse a vaccination program
by any local government as you see
but the problem of uh vaccine hesitancy
is beyond just
you know the complicated and
contradictory statements of the
government
it started in 2017 when president
rodrigo duterte's government also
conducted an investigation
into dengvaxia which was a dengue
vaccine being tried
on children here during the time of
former president benigno aquino
the investigation was played out before
the general public for months
and according to experts that actually
increased the level of vaccine hesitancy
here in the country so it is a problem
more than just
it is a problem not just access but also
for the public to actually trust the
vaccine in particular for example
vaccines coming from china has very low
um trust ratings compared to vaccines
coming from the us and other western
countries but the problem again is
supplies because there are more cyanobac
vaccines here
than pfizer or moderna which even has
yet to arrive here in the philippines
foley
so a question of of uh you say
what about access to these vaccines you
mentioned the chinese vaccine
uh how you know what what's the
situation as far as vaccine
availability is in the philippines
well the philippines has already availed
over a hundred
i think millions millions uh of vaccines
from the kovacs facility and of course
with over a hundred million people in
over seven 7
107 islands the resources coming from
the kovac facility is not enough
so the government has been trying to
augment that shortage by ordering
millions of vaccines
from at least four manufacturers but as
you know it takes months before they are
able to arrive and they are slow to
arrive
and as mentioned this is an archipelago
so it's very very difficult to transport
vaccines
in many different areas in fact there
are a lot of government officials who
are complaining
that in many areas vaccines have yet to
arrive
so looking at the current rate uh when
it comes to
looking at the current process of
inoculation here in the philippines
there are experts
who are actually saying that it will
take at least three years
for the philippine government for the
country to actually
um achieve herd immunity with the
current process at this point at least
three years with over around five
percent
inoculated so far thank you very much
for that jamilah linda again live there
in manila